just a note if you haven't seen the
april fools video the ranking of the
toes then click on the link in the
description as i placed quite a
significant amount of effort into it and
people seem to enjoy it which is always
a delightful match
noam chomsky is known as the father of
modern linguistics and the field of
analytical philosophy and cognitive
science are replete with references to
the work of chomsky in my opinion this
is chomsky at his pinnacle stellar and
the most philosophically pointed i've
seen chomsky the most insightful i've
seen him and that's saying plenty given
the substantial amount of podcasts he's
been on this is the seventh time that
i've been blessed enough to speak with
professor chomsky and given the vein of
this channel the toe channel we stick
with philosophy consciousness and
meaning rather than say politics there's
a playlist with each of chomsky's
theories of everything appearances
catalogued below
click on the timestamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the underrived nature of
reality the constitutional laws that
govern it provided those laws exist at
all and are even noble to us if you
enjoy witnessing and engaging with
others on the topics of psychology
consciousness physics etc the channels
themes then do consider going to the
discord and the subreddit which are
linked in the description there's also a
link to the patreon that is patreon.com
kirchheimengl if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuously
groups visit brilliant.org
toe t-o-e to get 20
off an annual subscription and i
recommend that you don't stop before
four lessons i think you'll be greatly
surprised at the ease at which you can
now comprehend subjects you previously
had a difficult time grocking the second
sponsor is algo now algo is an
end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce return and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by amjad hussein who's been a
huge supporter of this podcast since
near its inception in fact amjad has his
own podcast on ai and consciousness and
business growth and if you'd like to
support the tow podcast then visit the
link in the description to see amjad's
podcast because subscribing to him or at
least visiting supports the toe podcast
indirectly thank you and enjoy so number
one putnam in 1979 argued that the
indispensability of mathematics to
empirical science gives us a good reason
to believe in the existence of
mathematical entities according to this
line of argumentation reference to or
quantification over mathematical
entities such as sets numbers functions
and such is indispensable to our best
scientific theories and so we ought to
be committed to the existence of these
mathematical entities to do so would
otherwise would be called intellectual
dishonesty at least in putnam's mind in
1979 moreover these mathematical
entities are seen to be on the same
epistemic par with other theoretical
entities of science since belief in the
existence of the former is justified by
the same evidence that confirms the
theory as a whole this argument is known
as the quine putnam indispensability
argument for mathematical realism so
what is your opinion on this sir
well in the first place i
think it's a bit unfair
to accuse
coin
goodman others of intellectual
dishonesty
because they
worked on
what they called constructive nominalism
which was an effort to reconstruct uh
our
knowledge and understanding
on
the basis with denial of the existence
of sets
i don't think that was intellectually
dishonest
i think it was quite a reasonable effort
on the part of
quine and goodman
the coin abandoned it later goodman came
to it uh secondly if we
there's a bit there's considerable
difference between
numbers
sets
and
let's say atoms or chairs
uh i think i'm sure putnam would agree
so
as he knows
new better than i do
there's no
clear notion of said
there's a reasonably clear notion of
number putting aside
non-standard theories so we can assume
number to be understood
set is
a
famous statement by the
mathematician chronicler
uh that
god gave us the natural numbers
and everything else is a human creation
of course he didn't mean it literally
he meant
natural numbers are just somehow there
uh
we can try to understand them but they
have their properties and so on sets
are concepts that we develop
first of all there isn't any such thing
as a set just a set of something
then if we talk about what are the right
what's the right form of set theory
there are different approaches
so you can have an
axiomatic set theory like zamelo frankel
you can have constructivist set theories
uh which just develop as people's
intuition develops
their different forms of set theory
then
quite beyond that
uh take the difference between
numbers and uh
what what is postulated in uh
in scientific theories
like atoms
or
at one time in history uh phlegin
or caloric
uh
they're different
i mean
uh when
say a star
uh
can go out of existence
three can't go out of existence
uh if the universe as scientists now
believe
the consensus belief
if this universe is going to
end in the
darkness
end of time
everything disappears
numbers aren't going to disappear
they weren't they were there
before
uh
atoms
appeared they were there before
stars appeared they're in some
different
category
so even if we accept the argument
which is reasonable
that
if they're
indispensable for scientific theories we
have no good reason to deny their
existence
their existence is of a very different
kind
and this kind of discussion i think just
misses that uh
misses that distinction which of course
is what has bothered people
what kind of exists not elsewhere
putnam regularly correctly points out
that we use the word there exists in
many different ways
and i think that's a positive
we talk about the existence of numbers
the
existence of stars
we're talking about very different
different things
does that mean that numbers are somehow
more real than the universe or do we use
the word real in different ways as well
to say that something is real is just to
say that it is
real is an honorific term
so when i say
something is really true
it's no different than saying it's true
other than i emphasize it
you should believe it it's important
it's really true
if i say
uh
numbers are real
somehow means
can't dispense with them they play a
role in our thinking
that's gone we have every
reason to suppose that
there's
some sort of such entity we have no idea
what it is
okay we'll move on to question two which
says what's the relationship between
content and meaning
it seems like taking the same text and
tweaking how one delivers it maybe the
meaning the intonation changes the
meaning so for example you can act out
shakespeare and you could read it
silently in your head or you can read it
aloud and that's different than it being
in a movie or being in a comic book they
seem to have different meanings despite
the text being the same so what's the
relationship between the text and the
meaning or the content and the meaning
perhaps i shouldn't use the word content
synonymously with text
well the simple relation between content
and meaning
is we have no clear notion of either of
them
oh this is
reminiscent of
alan turing's
statement in his
famous
1950 article
which founded
the field of artificial intelligence
the oracle was a
can machines think
and what he said is
the question
can machines think is too meaningless to
deserve discussion
because we
don't know what we mean by think except
very loosely
so what's the point of
what we can do is if we can try to pose
a specific question and see if we can
answer that question
the specific question was his imitation
game
so-called turing test we'll take the
relation in content and meaning
meaning is a term of
the english language
it's a very complex term
it's very hard to translate even into
very similar languages
there's no
close
closely corresponding term and even
languages like french and german let
alone more remote ones
content
of course is also an english word
but it's a term of philosophical
discourse
philosophers have invented
a term which they pronounce content
and use it in some technical sense
depending on who's unity if it's jerry
fodor it means this if it's
uh michael domit it means that
so
you can't ask about the relationship
between
the technical term that someone invents
and
uses in a particular way
and a term of the language
meaning
as for the rest of the
comment it's quite correct the
way we
speak
uh
what's
when we're
thinking to ourselves when we're acting
on a stage when
i'm talking to you
all these different ways uh give
a different mode of understanding of
what i'm saying
in
loose
informal english
we say it gives it a different meaning
even though the literal meaning is the
same
so that's true
and uh
nothing very much to say about it except
describing it
there's no theory of it we can describe
it in various ways
someone with
more
literary talent than i have could give a
better description
but
that's about where we are number four so
are all words contrast words which is
just a word that i'm giving it which
means to understand the concept of dog
one needs to know what is not a dog some
people say this but i imagine they're
not linguists they're just imprecisely
saying this so if this is the case then
to me then the word everything slash the
universe would have to imply that one
has a conception of what's not included
in everything but then you get some
paradox there because if you have an
understanding of what's not included in
the word everything you can include that
in the word everything
so is that true that to understand a
word we do so by understanding what that
word means in contrast to what it's not
well if we
if
there is nothing that is not a dog
then we don't understand the word dog
the word dog
and every substantive word
if we understand it at all
we understand that some things don't
fall under that concept
actually what a dog is is not a trivial
matter
if you look into it the meaning of the
word dog is quite intricate
it's not a matter of just
picking out an object in the world
independent of our mind that doesn't
work
but
the microphone in front of me is not a
dog
at least that much is clear
with regard to the word
the universe well
we do have a concept of things that are
not in it
like uh
unicorns for example
they're not in the universe
zeus is not in the universe uh
lots of things that we think about are
not in the universe
things we once thought were in the
universe
we now think are not in the universe
plagian for example
there were once
good theories serious scientific
theories
which developed properties of phlogiston
we now have different theories which
don't postulate it
so then
we took it to be in the universe now we
take it out of the universe
the words like
all and everything are in a different
category they're not substantive words
so we understand them just by their
logical properties
not with regard to things they exclude
i noticed that you
skipped one was that on purpose or yeah
only because i had a question about when
turing said meaninglessness that if he
was to say so and so is meaningless then
to me
one has to understand meaninglessness in
terms of meaning
and if we're saying well it's
meaningless because we don't have a
great concept of meaning then to me that
would imply we don't have a great
concept of meaninglessness
well what turing was saying
we don't have a clear concept of
thinking
and since we don't have a clear concept
of meaning
there's no point in trying to ask
questions like
can machines think
machine remember maintenance program
can we programs a theory so he's asking
basically can we have a theory of
thinking
well not unless we know what we're
talking about
so in that sense it's meaningless
it doesn't there's no significance to
what we're saying he's using the word
meaningless in the ordinary informal
sense
where some things
just have no significance like asking uh
how many uh
how many
legs does
a unicorn have is
it's not a factual question
we can raise the question if we're
talking about mythology
then we can say four legs but
the question how much how does it many
does it really have
not a
question
i understand okay so we can get to
question three which we skipped which is
what's the difference between reference
and referent we spoke about this before
and you mentioned one was mental and the
other one was not mental or one was
subjective and the other was objective i
wanted you to re-explain that if you
don't mind
well we can start with
the relation of reference
it's a technical notion
philosophers logicians used in a certain
way
if you take a look at the
tradition of
logical philosophy from
has earlier origins of course but in the
modern period
uh purse fraga
tarsky uh
carnap coin
uh
is a definite concept
concepts
captured in the
title of books like coins word and
object
the idea is there's a relation
between
a sign in first a sense
maybe a word in a language specific case
and some
extra mental entity
so relation between
the word
river in
to take the earliest example that was
studied carefully in classical greece
a river and
something out there
which is extra mental
that's the relation of reference
uh in a
in the sciences
it's a
it's a goal of the sciences
to construct systems
which actually have a relation of
reference
so
so it's a norm of the sciences if you're
working in chemistry say
to
uh develop concept id signs in person
sense say
concepts words which actually pick out
things
in the extramental world
so you want if you have the concept
cork
you are postulating
that out there somewhere outside of my
mind there are quarks
same with stars same with atoms
same with caloric
phlogiston that's the norm of the
sciences
but language
and human life are not formal science
so it's an empirical question
whether
human languages
have a relation of reference
the term referent
is derivative from this
it's the thing referred to
so if we have
quan's word and object
the
word
is the
sign
the referent is the object
uh
you know
quark
is the word and
the thing we assume is out there is
irreverent
but does natural language have that
property
well the
classical tradition
argued that it didn't
i think they were right
so if you go back to say aristotle
is uh
he gave as an example
the word house
said what's a house
and his
metaphysics
house
is a combination
of matter and form
the matter of the house is
bricks
timbers so on things a physicist could
find
looking at a house
the form of the house
is a basically a mental construction
it's the design
what the architect have in mind
the intended use and so on
something could look like a house
exactly
could be something totally different it
could be a library
it could be a stable
it could be a
an artistic object that you put on your
shelf could be all kinds of things and
look exactly like a house
in fact and if you look further at the
notion house it's much more complex
so our concept of house has a
designated exterior
it's an exterior so if i paint the house
brown
i'm painting the outside
suppose it's a one room school house
if i paint the school house
brown
it's on the outside
if i paint the room brown it's on the
inside
that's our way of conceiving the object
the object is the same and it gets much
more complex than that
i shouldn't qualify here
aristotle was talking metaphysics
what is a house
but if you look at his
theory of signs his semantic theory
he held
in on interpretation
that we have
internal signs which are universal
all people have them abstract
and the word is just
as the properties of the thing referred
to
so we can carry it over and say
for the word as well
it's
it's
has the properties of form and meaning
and it goes way beyond if you look more
closely
in the
17th century there was a
major
cognitive revolution
and these ideas were reinterpreted in
cognitive terms
and i think those are the terms in which
we can look at them
but the conclusion is
that house
is not a sign that refers to anything
there's no
entity in the
mind external world that a physicist
could look at and say this is a house
same is true of
the first example that was used before
aristotle river
pre-socratics heraclitus
who asked a pretty deep question
how can you cross the same river twice
he could have added how can it be you
both times
since
you've changed you didn't say that and
the river changed
so how can he cross the city how is it
the same river the same person
as soon as you start looking into that
turns out to be quite non-trivial
what we regard as the same river the
same person are very intricate notions
uh won't run through it here there's
literature about it
just to illustrate on
i live in arizona now on my way to work
i cross
relito river
i've never seen any water in it
longer term residents tell me that
during the monsoon water flows through
it but it's the relito river even though
it has no water
because of a mental construction
if
the town were
to paint a line in the middle
smooth it over
use it for commuting
it would be a highway but the object
wouldn't have changed in any more than
trivial ways
on the other hand you could make massive
changes in the object it would still be
the lido river
you could change the course for example
when water flows in it could go in the
opposite direction
you could split it into tributaries so
the story is that
what we understand to be a river
is something with complex
conceptual
mental properties
it can undergo radical changes and be
the same river
can undergo tiny changes and not be a
river at all
you look at every word in the
vocabulary even the simplest ones
that's the way it is
so
i think the conclusion is
uh natural language just doesn't have a
reference relation
uh that wouldn't have bothered
fraga
tarsky kornam
because they didn't think there was any
point in looking at natural language
anyway
he said let's just look at formal
systems which don't have the problems of
natural language so no bother to them
coin it's a little more ambiguous
if you look at his book word and object
the first half of it is
pretty much about
natural language and psychology
the second half is about what he calls
regimented language
that means pretty much what tarsky and
karna had in mind
conform to things we construct to be
better behaved for our purposes than
natural language
so that's a split
but
as just as a matter of empirical fact
i think languages
do not have this
structure the persian structure of
sign
referent interpretation
the uh just
so technically speaking
natural language doesn't have semantics
semantics
technically is the study of
reference the relation of untruth which
depends on referent
but that just doesn't seem to be a
property of natural language
it's not a property of all of natural
language or most of natural language
well it's part of
here we have a
decision to make
do we include scientific discourse
within natural language
i mean there are different there's the
kind of language that children acquire
without instruction
very rapidly so by two or three years
old the children have already acquired
all these concepts
they don't have any instruction then
very little experience but they're just
it's part of our natural design we're
designed to have these concepts then
there are other concepts
like say
cork
or adam
those are taught
and
if you want to call them part of
language okay but it's just a
it's a question without significance
it's a question of terminology
i see
okay so question number five have you
heard of daniel dennett's quinine qualia
argument
if not we can move on
well i read it
years ago and
maybe i'm not doing justice to it but
the way i understood it
you can check and see if this is
accurate
is as an argument
saying that the notion of qualia
plays no
clear
and constructive role
in our
account of the world including our
experience so we can dispense with it
because there's no theory of quality
basically actually as far as i recall
in check and see
he didn't discuss
the one
careful systematic
theory that uses qualia
namely
nelson goodman's
major work structure of appearance
which was
an attempt to
redo
what carnap had done earlier in his
luggage of
their build
uh
kornap had tried to construct a
logis alpha logical construction to the
world
based on
objects
and goodman
re-did it
not talking about the world but just
about appearance
on the basis of qualia
and that's a systematic theory that uses
the notion qualia with a lot of
interesting results
so within
i don't know what bennett would say
about this i don't think he discussed it
it's the one
case that i know of a
serious theoretical
construction based on quality and has
i think quite interesting results
but it's the structure of appearance
remember actually i knew goodman pretty
well i was a student of his he had in
mind
a second volume
which would be the structure of
the world
never got to that
it was very hard to even get to the
structure of appearance
have you read daniel dennett's
consciousness explained book
and if so do you feel like it was
explained consciousness has been
explained
has a lot of
clever observations
it's interesting to read i think it
leaves consciousness where it was
in fact the question of explaining
consciousness
is a very curious one
i mean these it's a modern concern
till pretty recently consciousness was
not a major issue in philosophy
when it entered
at first during the
great modern early modern period
the notion consciousness was used for
self-consciousness
awareness of
one's own mind the
modern problem was called by david
chalmers the hard problem that's
basically the last century
as far as i can see the
best approach to it
to the so-called problem was actually
given by bertrand russell a century ago
i
pointed out
i think correctly
that our
what we are most confident about
is our own experience
the rest of our intellectual efforts
our attempts to make some sense of it
science for example
is an effort to see if you can
make some sense of
consciousness conscious experience
and he pointed out as well that
we would like to explain
consciousness in material terms
but the problem is we have no idea what
material is
for example we don't know whether
all matter has consciousness
arthur eddington his friend and
colleague scientist pointed out that
we don't know that
atoms don't have consciousness we don't
have a clear enough understanding of the
basis of it
so as
in recent work
gail and straws and
fine young philosophers
picked this up and pointed out i think
correctly
that it's not consciousness this has to
be explained that we understand very
well
we can describe it in extensive detail
uh what we don't understand is matter
so when you talk about
explaining consciousness trying to
account for it in material terms
the roadblock is we don't know what
material terms are
in fact that's true
you can pick up a
journal of
quantum mechanics recent journal
somebody just sent me one
which is symposium of
leading quantum physicists
trying to figure out what a particle is
they don't know
we know we have to postulate particles
we know what they are
the same
matter is a very
i mean there was a concept of matter
in the
early modern scientific revolution
so-called mechanical philosophy but that
was
shattered by newton
and though he didn't believe it
and regarded it as observed but
science has since accepted it
and that leaves us without a
clear notion of what matters
consciousness we understand as much as
you can understand anything
okay since we're on this track can we go
on to question number 22
which is
a question from davey who says to
professor chomsky the mind body problem
how can chomsky make the transposition
from newton's demolishment of the notion
of physical in the natural sciences to
the rejection of the concept of body in
the mind-body problem does this
dismissal mean that professor chomsky
believes there is no material world and
only the mental aspects
well we're talking about the 17th
century
and the 17th century body just meant
some part of the physical world
it was
there's a narrower sense of body in
which it means my shoulder my arms and
so on but they weren't talking about
that
uh actually descartes was in his
the last volume of his uh
lemon
which was never published
out of concern for the church
and but there he does talk about
you know the structure of the body you
know
in the narrow sense of body
you know your ribs your digestive system
and so on you're thinking
how they're related it's where he brings
up the pineal gland
pineal gland as the point in which
they're connected so there he's using a
narrower sense of body but the
discussion about body is just discussion
about matter
so it's not
my
distinction it's just right you have no
notion of matter
you have no notion of body
uh this stuff here
is all made of matter
and if i don't understand what matter is
i
i'm gonna have some understanding what
this is but that's consciousness the
things i we all understand but when you
ask what's it constituted of
well
some kind of whatever the world is
constituted of
but since newton we have
no real concept of that
physical material body that's just
whatever we think the world is
constituted of
i'm in uh
physicist
john wheeler the
institute for advanced study
once advanced a
theory that's called it from bit
says the only thing that exists in the
universe
is bits of information
answers to questions that we pose
fit
everything else the it part is just our
constructions from that
i don't know if it's a good theory or
not i'm not that competent the physicist
but suppose it is
okay that's matter
it's if it's something else okay
uh right now
physicists are
in the strange situation
where they can't find
i think it's 95
of what they
have to assume
uh the world is constituted of
dark matter dark energy
can't find it it's got to be there or
the
the
the predictions don't come out the
theory doesn't work so it's got to be
there but you can't find it
whatever it is
that's matter
all of this on the last part of the
question
i've always been
persuaded by
what's called in the history of
philosophy
lock suggestion
referring to john locke's
reaction immediate reaction
to newton's principia which he knew at
once
uh
luck
well he put it within his
theological framework we can restrain it
restate it without the theological
framework but
putting it in his terms
just as
god
provided matter
with properties that we cannot
comprehend
as
mr newton has shown
so god might have
super added to matter
the property of thought
meaning certain
organized
parts of
whatever the world consists of
maybe something in our brain
uh produces thought
just as
general matter has properties like
attraction and repulsion
can't understand it but that's the way
god made things
well that's block suggestion it led to a
century of
careful inquiry
into how
organized
matter whatever matter is can produce
thought
david hume
joseph priestley
lemaitre
many others finds its way to
darwin's notebooks just as
you know
the liver produces
bile why can't the brain produce
thoughts
that was the idea through the 19th
century
then 18th century then pretty much
forgotten
interestingly it was revived
in the last decade of the 20th century
regarded as a
radical new idea in the history of
philosophy
uh thinking is just a property of
organized matter
uh
astonishing hypothesis and so on
the new idea
in modern biology
repeating in almost verbatim
uh the writings of the 18th century
i've written about this so it was
rediscovered and if there's an
alternative i don't know what it is
uh
thinking
what's mental
is just
some kind of property of certain types
of organized matter
notice this leaves open what matters
whatever it turns out to be whatever the
world is constituted of
but certain organizations of it
do have the property of thought
and we can now say a fair amount about
that
we know that it's above the neck not
below the neck so you can cut off my arm
i still think the same way
decapitate me i don't think the same way
and when you look inside the head
it's not in the nose it's in the brain
you can find particular parts of the
brain which
implicated in one or another kind of
thought so
you can now carry out the
17th century
insights lock
in
more specific directions so as to
whether
there's no material world only the
mental aspects
there's a material world by definition
the material world we define as whatever
there is
so there's something not nothing
so therefore there's a material world
whatever it is we don't know what it is
we don't know what its properties are we
know some of its properties
like some of its properties are
attraction and repulsion
other of its properties are thinking
many other properties
mental aspects of the world are just
part of the material world
don't see any point in distinguishing
them
there are chemical aspects of the world
there are mental aspects to the world
of course they're different we can study
them and so on
but i don't see
um there is a kind of
methodological dualism
which holds that we have to study
the mind differently from other parts of
the world
uh
quine was an example of this
his approach to
mental aspects of the worlds in word and
object
was radically unscientific in my view
i've written about this
didn't just treated it dogmatically
uh language is a
a complex of dispositions to verbal
behavior acquired by conditioning
it's an edict it's not a scientific
proposal
and it collapses instantly on
examination
but it didn't matter
because we keep to
methodological dualism we don't use the
methods of science when we
study the mind of course quine would
deny that and did deny it but if you
look at it i think that's
the right conclusion
and you can say the same thing about all
of behaviorism
behaviorism i think was a radical
departure from the
sciences i mean the sciences uh
typical
comment about the sciences which i think
is fair enough is
john pierre baptist physicists
nobel prize
lecturer when he won the physics prize
he said
the goal of science is to
discover the
simple invisibles
that lie behind the complex visibles
behavioral science is saying let's just
look at the complex visibles
we're not allowed to look at the hidden
invisibles in other words we're not
allowed to do science
you can't think of a more radical
departure from science and for the 20th
century it's been considered scientific
i think that's a
serious departure from science which
swept the intellectual world
so
maybe you don't want to label yourself
but would you call yourself an idealist
sorry
would you consider yourself to be an
idealist or no
no
but except normal science
i think we should accept normal science
we
try to discover what constitutes the
world
and how its various aspects work
so it's chemical aspects
it's mental aspects
to
other aspects of the world
try to find out what they are and
see if
physicists will be able to discover what
constitutes the world
but going back to russell
i think he was right to say
that it's not
consciousness that needs explaining it's
matter that needs explaining
consciousness we know all about
more than we know about anything else
not or we have problems with
am i to understand that as saying it's
not consciousness we need to explain but
unconsciousness or are you making a
distinction between matter and
unconsciousness unconsciousness too but
also matter
it's uh what is
um if you want to
what's called reducing consciousness
to the material world
can't do that until you know what the
material world is
you can describe consciousness in
extensive detail
uh as i say the best descriptions are in
literature
where consciousness
that's what it's about
what does my protagonist think and feel
extensive detail and we can do it for
ourselves
when i
you ask a question
what constitutes this thing we don't
know
that's where the problems arise
when i'm thinking about this question
of well what is a cup and let's forget
about it that is natural language let's
just imagine we're talking what is an
atom what is an atom and then we say
well we don't know exactly what an atom
is and then i wonder well what
explanation could one possibly give
that would satisfy
someone so that they wouldn't say well
we don't know what that is so let's say
we explain the atoms in terms of
something else then we can say that
again and again is there something at
the bottom that we can say okay now we
understand it now we know what that is
well we've known
since the 17th century that there isn't
going to be any
any
answer to that question
that we can
accept with certainty
empirical questions
we can try to find
the best theories
the best explanatory theories
but we can never be certain that they're
true
that's been understood since the 17th
century
since the collapse of
the mechanical philosophy
uh
so we just have to live with that
we live in a world in which we can seek
best explanations
but uh that's it now maybe it's possible
to go further
maybe
leibniz's
principle of sufficient reason
can carry us further
leibniz
argued
the familiar phrase is we live in the
best of all possible worlds but there's
a much deeper theory behind it
saying that nature
necessarily
constructs the best possible world
nothing else is possible if
you hang a string of beads they're going
to go in a perfect form
not they're not going to go in a square
because nature always
necessarily
seeks the simplest solution
and then there's a background for that
in the principle of sufficient reason
and so on
well if that's correct and it
it's had it's been an amazingly
productive idea
every in fact galileo had said something
similar but
more loosely said
the world is
nature is simple and our task is to
prove it
that's uh
blindness had a much deeper theory and a
mathematical theory and some of the
great mathematicians worked on this
to try to show that it's got to be true
and if you look at
the results of the sciences
anywhere you understand something it's
true
uh
many great scientists have come and
commented on this
said the mysterious thing
is not that there are laws
but they're always simple laws
and if they're not simple laws we find
they're wrong
well leidness had a general argument to
that effect
and if you can
sometimes it's called the magical
property of science
always
if you get anything like the right
answer it's always the simplest answer
as i say leibniz said
arguments for that and the great
mathematicians of the 17th century
worked on it to try to prove it
decor others
the uh
if that's true
then
there's something
that should we should be certain about
whatever is simplest is going to be true
but that leaves a lot of questions open
like our understanding of simplicity
plus
the impact of the law of sufficient
reason
so we're in difficult territory
but the simplest point to say is we just
can't be confident
about our
empirical conclusions
actually that
goes back a little bit to the first
question you asked
we can't assume
that because something is needed
by our flawed theories
that it's therefore necessarily true
but we can't because our theories are
flawed and we know it
number 11 here's something i've been
wondering when someone's trying to
articulate their feelings one often
searches for the right word or right set
of words to express an intuition which
isn't precisely formed so it's imprecise
let's say at the gut level at an
intuitive level
sometimes we express different words
aloud and we're trying to get to it we
do this often in therapy or when we're
talking with a friend to try to get to
the root of the issue we say no that's
not it that's not why i'm upset with jim
for example and then maybe the friend
says are you upset because two years ago
he snubbed you at the party then you say
oh okay that's it yes that's it
so this obviously isn't just limited to
that it could also be
sometimes when we're scrolling around on
tv we feel like i'm in the mood for some
show but i don't know what show it is
and then you find the show he said yes
i'm in the mood for that exact show so
what is happening here it seems like we
have something that's imprecise
and then somehow something explicit
comes and we match it but we matched it
with something that was imprecise so is
the imprecise part of us actually
precise and how are we even able to do
this matching
that raises
very interesting questions
i think what
it leads to is that most of our mental
life
is unconscious and inaccessible to
consciousness
this is opposed to various
dogmas
that are
held in the philosophical literature
so john searle for example has
argued that
a necessary property of the mantle is
that you can bring it to consciousness
well
unfortunately
our mental life is beyond the level of
consciousness
just as we can't become conscious of the
way our digestive system works
you know something about your digestive
system when you have a stomach ache
but if you want to study
how it works and it is a major nervous
system kind of like the
nervous system up here
you have to study it
as philosophers put it from a third
person point of view from the outside
and the same is true of our mental life
we can only study it from the outside
we can't introspect into it
you can show this pretty clearly in the
study of language
when you look closely at the nature of
language
one of the maybe the only area where
we can study this clearly
maybe geometry
shapes and so on but to a much richer
extended language
when we look into it
we find that the best theories of
language
hence the ones we
tentatively accept on
putnam and coins grounds though they
didn't go to this conclusion they
rejected it but if we accept their
arguments as i think we should
then we should tentatively accept the
best explanatory theories of language
and those theories contrary to their
conclusions
tell us that there's
a system of
computation going on in the mind
which is producing
internal thoughts
which then we struggle
to articulate but they're there inside
and the kinds of examples that are
discussed here show it
we all see this all the time
when you're writing for example
you write a sentence you look at it and
you say you know that's that's not what
i mean and try something else you know
maybe that's but closer
uh
there's what we call
inner speech
it's not in our speech
it's outer speech
what we call inner speech is
externalized language not what's going
on inside
so you can think two sentences and you
can ask do they rhyme for example
there's nothing in the internal system
that has anything to do with that
so in fact what if you introspect
what comes to consciousness are
fragments
bits and pieces of fragments
and amazingly they come
instantaneously
in very complicated ways
so take any
you walk into a room
you see a friend of yours sitting at the
table working on his computer you
remember
oh i wanted to tell him something
but then you notice that uh
there's another guy sitting there
who would be offended if you said this
so you better
say something else when you come over to
him then you go over maybe you say
something all of this happens
in an instantaneously
huge amount of thinking going on
we're not conscious of it you get little
bits and fragments here and there
but it's all going on in everything we
do
in the study of language you can
actually pinpoint it
you can have time to do it here but you
can pinpoint things that are in the
internal language which don't get
expressed
but must be in the internal language as
we see from the way
it works generally
other consequences best theory
explanations again
so if we could overcome the
methodological dualism
that quine
was immersed in
and i'm afraid put them too very often
and
accept their conclusions look at the
best theories that we have
if you can improve them fine
look at the best theories we have accept
their assumptions tentatively
when we do
we conclude i think what we just
described what i just described
a lot of mental computation going on
bits and pieces of it
reaching awareness
fragments usually
but so interpenetrated
with what's conscious that you just
can't study them separately
study of consciousness is never going to
get anywhere
unless it introduces it integrates
itself with a much richer study
where we understand much more
of the unconscious
inaccessible
mental processes that are underway
they interpenetrate so
closely you can't separate one from
another so i don't think consciousness
studies are going to get very far unless
they
begin to integrate them
into the
rich complex
inaccessible mental processes that are
inaccessible to come
to
consciousness my opinion
two problems with consciousness studies
one is the one i mentioned before
russell's problem
the problem is matter not consciousness
the second is this one what's conscious
can't be
sensibly
disentangled
from what's unconscious and inaccessible
disentangled is one of
hillary putnam's favorite words
incidentally a lot of his philosophical
work is
arguing that you can't disentangle
things this is one example i think
not his exam
when i was speaking to
professor
michael levin i was asking him about
consciousness studies and he said there
is no consciousness studies because
consciousness to study it is a first
person activity however what you're
outlining sounds like we need more third
person if you want to study it it's
going to be third person
we study things from the outside
russell i think was right
our conscious experience is what we are
most confident about
when we study our conscious experience
we discover that it's not given
it's the result of many other things
and it's often mistaken
about other things
but that's our
further
scientific intellectual inquiry into the
nature
of
what we are immediately aware of
so the fact that it's first person i
don't think has much to do with anything
yes of course it's first person
and the rest of our inquiries are
third-person efforts to find out what it
is
and how it relates to the rest of the
world
the last question what happens is we
have wobbles we quibble over definitions
people do this and scholars do this for
example what's the definition of life
infamously there are 12 to 20 to 30
different definitions same with
computation same with what does it mean
to be a woman though that maybe is on
the more political end but it's the same
idea what are we quibbling over it
reminds me of what we just talked about
whereas we have an intuitive notion of
what the word life means and then we
have an ostensive definition where we
point to different objects or well we
point to different entities and we say
this for sure satisfies the definition
of life these ones perhaps maybe these
ones not so much so then let's capture
it firstly is my account of how we
generate a definition correct and is
fighting over these definitions of a
waste of time why or why not
well let's take
one of the examples he gave computation
now that is an old idea
computing things
but there was in the mid 20th century
an answer to the question
what is computation
which is an absolute answer to quote
kirk girdle
uh namely turing's definition
uh girdle concluded i think plausibly
that this answers the question precisely
what is computation
it's absolute doesn't depend on your
point of view or anything else
now of course it's not the intuitive
notion
but it's
a technical notion which captures
what's essential to the intuitive notion
and gives us a precise
concept which then has
been developed in
very rich and complicated ways into
theory of computation
recursive function theory very rich part
of mathematics leads right into the
empirical sciences
it was the crucial step for linguistics
that allowed it to make the move from
vague
studies of production to precise studies
of generation
that's modern linguistics
based on
touring post girdles
development of a precise notion of
computation
and that's i think what we should be
aiming for in these other cases like
take life
we have an intuitive concept
like you're alive but
this cup is not alive so we have a
starting point
our virus is alive well
not so clear
what we need is
better
explanatory theories of the way the
world works
and to the extent we construct these
theories
will have answers not to the question of
what it what is life
but to a coherent
clear
concept of how the world works which
captures
fundamental properties of what we're
struggling about when we talk about life
so the quibbles aren't
useless
unless they just
collapse into discussions of terminology
but if there are ways of exploring
the different aspects of the world to
try to find
what are the
real
qualities of the world and here i'm
descending to the metaphysical realism
that
hillary spent most of his work trying to
oppose
then
we're doing something useful
is there a name for it because i'm
extremely interested in studying how is
it we come up with definitions and how
is it when we know that what we've
articulated matches our intuition is
there a name for that
science
i mean is there a name like it's a
subfield of linguistics like semiotics
or some feel like is there a name for it
semiotics is
just the general theory of science
uh
actually i once
listened to a lecture happened to be in
paris by
a leading figure in semiotics it was to
a general scientific seminar
he started by saying
that
semiotics has two branches
one is language the other is traffic
signals
we can say something about those two
topics
it was joking of course
but the point is
you can have a general field let's talk
about signs and wave your hands and so
on
but
you can try to carve out
some parts of it
where you can develop
serious explanatory theories
that give you insight and understanding
into how some parts of the world work
well is it the original quest not quite
original quest was much broader and
looser
but it's carving out areas where you can
gain understanding and insight
and that's science
or rational inquiry generally
okay thank you professor i know that you
have to get going i appreciate this
and hopefully next time if there's the
next time we could get to some of the
other questions as well
hope so
thank you sir
yeah sorry i have to leave okay and if
anyone who's watching this knows of the
field or subfield of linguistics if it's
even within linguistics of the study of
definitions that is how we come up with
the explicit definitions for an implicit
for an imprecise intuition as well as
how we articulate and then know that
we've matched what we have articulated
as well as what i'm extremely interested
in is how is it that we come up with a
definition for example life when it was
contingent on certain examples like
let's say
we consider
ourselves to be alive frogs to be alive
the sun to be alive
and
the grass to be alive and perhaps even
snowy mountains to be alive
we then extract the definition of life
which then contradicts the data points
we used to come up with the pattern that
produced that definition of life so we
no longer consider fire or the sun or
mountains to be alive so i'm extremely
interested in that the whole field if
it's even a field of articulating
definitions if anyone here happens to be
within the field of linguistics and
knows any papers or research that i
should do to learn more about the
subject then please do let me know thank
you so much for watching usually when i
produce a podcast i tend to re-watch it
maybe at most once whereas this one i
think i'm going to rewatch a couple of
times i found it to be the best one that
has been done on this channel with noam
chomsky that's saying plenty because
there may be six others so there's seven
in total the playlist for those will be
in the description
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you